Turquía es el Diego Armando MARADONA de los países. También tuvo un pasado glorioso
pero en los últimos años, cada vez que salen
en los medios es porque ha ocurrido algo realmente
malo. Nos habéis pedido que hagamos un vídeo
explicando lo que está pasando en Turquía
y, creedme, se trata de un auténtico peligro.
Y no, por si alguno se lo estaba preguntando,
esta vez la culpa no es de Donald Trump. Es
más, las sanciones de Estados Unidos son
sólo la punta del iceberg. Un iceberg que
puede hacer que muchos barcos se hundan. Y,
en este caso, los barcos son los bancos europeos.
Fijaos en este mapa. Turquía es el puente
entre Europa y Asia. Hablamos de un país
con tanta población como Alemania. Un país
donde Europa ha estado invirtiendo desde hace
décadas. Empresas, fábricas y sobretodo,
muchos préstamos. Para que os hagáis una
idea… ¿Habéis oído hablar del BBVA? SE
trata del segundo banco más grande de España.
Pues bien, Turquía es su tercer mercado más
importante. En otras palabras, que si los
turcos estornudan, muchos europeos se van
a resfriar.
¿Qué decís? ¿Qué todavía no estáis
asustados? Pues atentos…
Turquía es uno de los miembros más importantes
de la OTAN. Después de Estados Unidos, son
el ejército más numeroso de la alianza.
Y además, es uno de los pocos países de
mayoría musulmana que tiene una constitución
laica. Al menos… por el momento.
Y sí, habéis oído bien, hemos dicho “por
el momento”. Lo cierto es que al presidente
turco, RECEP TAYYIP ERDOGAN, eso del laicismo
le suena bastante mal.
Erdogan es algo así como el Anakin Skywalker
de la política. Empieza siendo el bueno de
la película pero todos sabemos que, tarde
o temprano, terminará cayendo en el lado
oscuro… En este caso el lado oscuro es una
mezcla entre fanatismo religioso y populismo
de la vieja escuela.
Erdogan se presenta como el defensor de los
turcos de a pie. Esos turcos que viven en
las zonas rurales de KONYA, completamente
ajenos al glamour de ESTAMBUL. Son los turcos
que no cobran grandes sueldos y que mantienen
un estilo de vida tradicional ¿Y de quién
los defiende? Pues por supuesto, de la conspiración
occidental que quiere acabar con la Turquía
de toda la vida.
Eso explica que, para la propaganda de Erdogan,
noticias como esta sean tan importantes.
Estados Unidos impone sanciones a oficiales
turcos por un Pastor Estadounidense detenido
Sin embargo, todo esto no es más que la punta
del iceberg. La crisis de Turquía se lleva
cociendo desde hace más de dos años ¡Y
no sólo hablamos de una crisis política!
En realidad, lo más problemático de Turquía
es la economía. Hablamos de una Venezuela
en miniatura a las puertas de Europa.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero qué está pasando
en Turquía? ¿Qué ha pasado en este país
para que hayan caído en el lado oscuro de
la economía? ¿De verdad hay razones para
asustarse? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
ERDOGAN: EL SALVADOR
Turquía es un país famoso por varias cosas:
Santa Sofía, el Kebab y… la inflación.
Desde el año 1970 hasta el año 2000, Turquía
sufría unas inflaciones brutales. Muchos
año llegaron a superar el 100%. Eso significa
que, de un año para otro, los precios se
duplicaban.
¿Y qué pasa cuando tienes tantísima inflación
y estás a las puertas de Europa? Pues que
te conviertes en algo así como la Disneylandia
de la mano de obra barata. Empresas como RENAULT
o PEUGEOT construyeron montones de fábricas
en Turquía. Y diréis: eso son buenas noticias
para un país ¿no?
Pues si, y a la vez no.
Por ejemplo, en los años 60, Renault montó
una fábrica en Bursa, que es una ciudad al
Norte de Turquía. Producir coches en Bursa
era muy barato para Renault. Si la Lira Turca
se devaluaba año tras año, Renault tenía
que pagar cada vez sueldos más bajos. Sin
embargo, una vez ganaban el dinero ¿Lo guardaban
en el país? ¡Por supuesto que no! Si el
dinero pierde valor contínuamente, lo mejor
que puedes hacer es sacarlo lo antes posible.
Así que Turquía estaba condenada a no progresar…
Hasta el año 2003, año en el que Erdogan
llega al poder.
El gran objetivo de Erdogan era poner la inflación
por debajo del 10%. Y tan pronto como lo consiguió,
la economía turca dio un giro de 180 grados.
De repente, muchas empresas europeas se pusieron
a invertir en Turquia. Y eso incluye a los
bancos. Uno de ellos es BBVA, el segundo mas
importante de España. Y lo hizo a lo grande.
Para BBVA Turquía representa su tercer mercado.
En los años 2000, Turquía se puso de moda.
Seguridad jurídica significa que las empresas
podían reinvertir en el país. En menos de
10 años, los turcos pasaron de cobrar unos
800 dólares al mes de media a superar los
1200 dólares.
¡No sólo eso! En estos primeros años de
Erdogan, aparecieron nuevos sectores como
el Turismo. Turquía pasó de tener 13 millones
de turistas a 39.
¿Y qué me decís de las empresas turcas?
¿Habéis oído hablar de TURKISH AIRLINES?
En los años 90, Turkish Airlines era una
empresa de aviación más. Pero al poder reinvertir
sus beneficios, se han terminado convirtiendo
en un líder de aviación a nivel global ¡Y
no creáis que hablamos de un caso aislado!
Si hay un ejemplo del milagro turco, ese es
YILDIZ HOLDINGS. Hablamos de un grupo de alimentación
que empezó siendo una pastelería familiar
y que ha terminado comprando marcas internacionales
como la belga CHOCOLATES GODIVA o la británica
UNITED BISCUITS. Para que os hagáis una idea,
YILDIZ ha terminado siendo la tercera empresa
de alimentación del mundo.
En otras palabras, que la economía turca
estaba ON FIRE. Y cuando la economía está
ON FIRE, a nadie parece preocuparle que Erdogan
hubiera estado en la cárcel por militar en
un grupo radical. A fin de cuentas, el país
seguía siendo democratico y Erdogan era la
rockstar del mundo arabe. El elegido para
conducir a todo el mundo islámico hacia el
lado luminoso de la política.
Por aquellos años, Turquia se veia cada vez
mas como un pais europeo. A puntico de entrar
en la mismísima Unión Europea. Como dato
curioso, en 2003 llegaron a ganar en el Festival
de Eurovisión. Pero las negociaciones para
entrar en Europea se extendieron durante años
¿Y qué pasó entonces? Pues que a Erdogan
se le acabó la paciencia y dijo:
¡Ahá! Así que no soy lo suficiente “cool”
como para entrar en vuestro club ¿Verdad?
Pues os vais a enterar. Porque eso de ser
tan occidental, con separación de poderes,
laicismo y nosequemás se ha terminado. Ha
llegado el momento de…
LA NUEVA ERDOGANOMICS
En los ultimos 5 anos las cosas han empezado
a complicarse para Erdogan. Para empezar han
salido todo tipo de casos de corrupción que
le implican directamente. Pero, sin duda alguna,
lo más problemático han sido noticias como
esta:
Ataque al aeropuerto Ataturk de Estambul.
41 muertos y mas de 230 heridos
Los atentados del DAESH han llevado el terrorismo
islámico y el caos a las calles de Turquia.
Y el daño sobre el turismo ha sido inmediato.
En 2 años ha caido un 25%. Y esto es preocupante
si tenemos en cuenta que el turismo supone
el 13% de la economía turca. Pero hay mas
datos negativos. La inversión extranjera
ha caído ha la mitad. Y os preguntaréis
¿Por qué? Pues por dos razones. Una, cada
vez hay menos probabilidades de que el país
entre en la Unión Europea, y dos, el propio
Erdogan.
Y es que mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
el radicalismo islámico no sólo es un peligro
político. También es un peligro económico.
El presidente turco Erdogan dice que las tasas
de interés son la “madre de todos los males”
y la lira turca cae
Según Erdogan, la “ortodoxia económica”
es un invento de Occidente para desestabilizar
a Turquía. Y eso de prestar dinero a cambio
de un interés va en contra del Islam. Así
que, por su propia cuenta y riesgo, ha llegado
al Banco Central Turco y ha obligado a bajar
las tasas de interés al máximo posible y
a empezar a imprimir billetes ¿Y qué pasa
si el Banco Central se niega? Pues… estas
fueron sus palabras textuales.
“El banco central no puede utilizar su independencia
para rechazar las señales que le da el presidente”
–Erdogan en declaraciones para Bloomberg
En otras palabras, tras el intento de golpe
de estado de 2016, Erdogan ha caído definitivamente
en el lado oscuro. Según él, puede dirigir
la economía a su antojo. Y todo argumento
racional en contra de su política económica
es una conspiración occidental. Para que
os hagáis una idea, ha nombrado como ministro
de finanzas a su propio yerno. El nuevo paradigma
económico de Turquía no es ni liberal ni
socialdemócrata: es la Erdoganomics.
¿Qué necesita dinero para pagar su gasto
público? Lo imprime ¿Qué las empresas turcas
se quejan? Llena el mercado con crédito barato.
En menos de 2 años, los bancos turcos han
prestado más de 50.000 millones de dólares
a las pequeñas empresas. Y todo esto, prácticamente,
sin tipos de interés.
¿El resultado? Una megadevaluación de la
lira turca.
En el año 2014, el dólar estadounidense
se cambiaba por, aproximadamente, 2,5 liras.
En el momento en el que hacemos este vídeo,
el dólar se cambia por más de 6 liras. Es
decir, que la divisa turca ha bajado a casi
la tercera parte de su valor. Y eso explica
que la inflación en 2017, la inflación llegara
al 11.9%.
¡Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando! ¿11,9%?
¡Pues tampoco es una inflación tan alta!
En Argentina, sin ir más lejos tienen 3 veces
más inflación. Lo cierto es que hace falta
tiempo desde que una divisa se devalúa hasta
que la inflación empieza a subir ¿Y quienes
son los primeros en sufrir los efectos de
una devaluación? Pues las empresas que tenían
préstamos en bancos extranjeros ¡Y no son
pocas! ¿Os acordáis de YILDIZ HOLDINGS?
¿Ese gigante de la alimentación? Pues…
mirad, mirad…
El dueno turco de Chocolates Godiva reestructura
una deuda de 6.500 millones de dolares.
Se estima que la deuda extranjera de las empresas
turcas sobrepasa los 300.000 millones de dolares.
Para que os hagáis una idea, eso es lo que
han costado todos los rescates a la economía
de Grecia. Y mientras tanto, la inflación
que padecen los ciudadanos de a pie va creciendo
poco a poco. Este año 2018 ya ha alcanzado
el 15% y las previsiones ajenas al Gobierno
turco hablan ya de que a principios del 2019
estará en un 22%.
La calificacion crediticia de Turquia es rebajada
profundamente al bono basura mientras Standard
and Poors predice una recesión el próximo
año
A todo esto le tenemos que sumar las sanciones
que Trump está imponiendo a Turquía. Las
razones de estas sanciones son complejas así
que hablaremos de eso en otro vídeo.
Mientras tanto, en mitad de esta crisis, hay
un actor secundario que tiene mucho que perder:
La Unión Europea.
Bancos como el Español BBVA, el Francés
BNP Paribas o el Italiano Unicredit le han
prestado más de 190.000 millones de euros
a las empresas turcas. Y por el momento, el
BBVA ya ha perdido la mitad del valor de sus
inversiones en este país.
Así que ya os podéis imaginar el agujero
que dejaría un colapso de Turquía.
De momento Erdogan ha dicho que ni va a pedir
un rescate al Fondo Monetario Internacional
ni va a imponer control de capitales. Ahora
bien ¿Puede realmente mantener su palabra?
¡No lo sabemos! Por el momento, Qatar y China
han dicho que van a intentar ayudar pero todavía
es pronto para ver lo que va a ocurrir.
Asi que la pregunta ahora es para vosotros.
¿Puede Turquía convertirse en la Venezuela
Europea? ¿Hasta que punto esto puede desatar
una nueva crisis en toda Europa? Es mas ¿Puede
Erdogan arrastrarnos a todos al lado oscuro?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Mientras tanto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo. Un
abrazo y hasta pronto.